ministre la parole est à monsieur
thierry mariani la question la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
je crois que chacun dans cet hémicycle
connaît le mérite de la grande majorité
des agents de la fonction publique qui
travaillent consciencieusement mais se
mérite doit pas nous aveugler et se
mérite de doigts malgré ce mérite
j'allais dire nous devons mettre le
doigt sur le taux d'absentéisme dans la
fonction publique qui mes chers
collègues deviennent de plus en plus
importants et fini par coûter cher à la
france
les rapports et études se succèdent mais
vous avez l'air de faire la sourde
oreille
dernier exemple selon le bilan social de
l'année 2014 qui a filtré récemment les
agents publics de pôle emploi serez
absent en moyenne trente six jours par
an pour maladie contre 17,1 pour les
agents du privé c'est à dire qu'à même
travail a même fonction dans la même
entreprise
il ya en clair le double de congés
maladie selon le statut autre exemple
monsieur le premier ministre
selon une étude sortie en juin 2015
réalisé par sofaxis l'an dernier 54
arrêts maladie pour cent agents ont été
dénombrés dans les collectivités locales
et vous le savez ce chiffre est reparti
à la hausse en 2014 en raison entre
autres de la suppression du jour de
carence dans la fonction publique en
2012 le précédent gouvernement avait
instauré la journée de carence pour les
fonctionnaires le nombre d'arrêts
maladie dans les collectivités
territoriales avaient diminué
considérablement
vous avez pour faire un cadeau aux
syndicats supprimer ce jour de carence
aujourd'hui on voit hélas les résultats
l'absentéisme dans toutes les fonctions
publiques est repartie à la hausse alors
ma question est simple
quelles sont vos solutions pour le
contribuable à qui cet absentéisme coûte
cher quelles sont vos solutions pour que
l'image des fonctionnaires ne soient pas
dégradées
quelles sont vos solutions pour tous les
français qui attendent un service public
de qualité qu'ils auraient dû et qui
aujourd'hui est dégradée par cet
absentéisme
la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs député monsieur le député
thierry mariani
d'abord merci d'avoir salué le travail
de nos fonctionnaires puisque nous
perdons beaucoup de postes pendant ce
mandat vous savez que l'entièreté des
postes créés dans l'éducation nationale
la police la justice et la défense
seront compensées et que nos équipes
réussissent à faire face dans des
situations en fait difficile de tension
avec un point d'un dijonnais je
regardais tout à l'heure un certain
nombre de communiqués donc les
fonctionnaires ne sont pas des
privilégiés moi je les remercie eux de
porter le service public et le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
après avoir dit ça comment on peut
répondre il faut qu' il faut rappeler à
ceux qui nous écoutent que les
fonctionnaires n'ont pas de régime de
protection complémentaire de protection
sociale complémentaire comme on peut
avoir dans le privé puisque comme vous
le savez très bien monsieur mariani 47 %
des employés des petites entreprises
n'ont pas de jour de carence parce
qu'ils sont couverts par une protection
complémentaire et 77 % des salariés des
groupes et quand vous donnez d'ailleurs
le chiffre de sofaxis c'est justement
madame pécresse on énerve c'est
justement les statistiques des salariés
qui ont eu à un bénéfice d'une
protection sociale complémentaire par
sofac 6 qui n'ont donc pas de jour de
carence et qui font leurs propres
statistiques donc vous venez de
démontrer qu'avec l'absence ou pas de
jour de carence le résultat et non
différents donc je vous en remercie je
vous rappelle monsieur mariani qu'après
la suppression du jour de carence nous
nous sommes engagés à contrôler tous les
arrêts maladie des fonctionnaires ce qui
n'est pas fait et par les caisses
primaires d'assurance maladie
il faudra dépenser un peu parce qu'elle
fera payer les médecins en question et
nous avons commencé l'expérimentation
qui est public
l'ex perret ne faut pas crier si fort
sinon sentons plus d'expérimentations
qui est public dans les alpes-maritimes
le bar à l'ille-et-vilaine le puy de
dôme rhône et paris et nous avons
effectivement 6% à justifier de jourda
d'art
mais contre 10 pour cent dans laricina
pas